j'accueille maintenant david guetta
grâce à ma baguette arrive il reconnaît
que ahmed
ouais bah pourquoi je vais te dire
pourquoi personnes ont surtout fait en
dix ans j'ai galéré pour rentrer en
boîte de nuit le sol la seule boîte de
nuit où je rentre assez tôt aux bains
douches grâce à la voix la mer comme en
vain cathy guetta mais ça va bien
comment va tim elvis tum elvis va très
bien il a quand même appelé son fils
thibault
en fait on l'appelle on l'appelle elvis
alors inhabitée email maxime c'était un
peu en fait tu arrivé je suis arrivé à
la mairie on avait décidé elvis et puis
au dernier moment je me suis dit que
quand même si vous voulez être banquier
ou effectivement leur prof de maths ou
avocat ça ne fait pas très sérieux de
lui donner le choix entre elvis s'il
voulait être artiste comme nous ou si
vous voulez faire un métier peut-être un
peu plus sérieux team efira il fera que
c'est sérieux estime bois par rapport à
moi déjà assez serré c'est plus sérieux
qu'elle vise haut tout comme mon mal en
pire guetta bon y'a pas d'empiré guetta
tu sois ici il ya quand même le temps
jianping platine nous l'avons vendu à et
aujourd'hui on s'occupe surtout cathy
d'ailleurs puisque moi je fais plutôt de
la musique en ce moment
du de la suite oui du pink paradise qui
est un club de strip tease qui marche
très très bien qui était le premier en
france et c'est devenu un classique
maintenant voilà en fait à des boîtes
actu quoi c'est pas tout à fait pareil
c'est oui y'a du cul mais ya pas que ça
c'est comme la télé mais voilà il ya la
musique donc puisque maintenant tu vas
musique c'est vrai dire surtout la nuit
tu as fait une entrée remarquée alors je
voudrais te remercie au passage parce
que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure dans le
danton sampler là le remis ce que j'ai
fait de david bowie toutes les semaines
mais alors je ne sais je suis vraiment
content j'adore cette rapide il a fait
un remix de heroes de bowie qui est
magnifique il l'a fait et ensuite ils
avaient peur que bowie soit pas d'accord
pour ça sorte et bowie a été d'accord
grâce à dieu c'est génial
ça toutes les semaines je le mets jeu
l'adorent maintenant il ya le troisième
album qui s'appelle guetta blaster voilà
tu as compris la vanne to play voilà des
propos ramène à nez avec un peu stricte
ont ce qu'on pensait marrant voilà
écoute j'aime la musique
étienne la musique est alors le morceau
en promo 10 ans s'appelle stay voilà
pas vous
voilà ce trait de guetta blaster donc le
nouveau cd je dois dire qu'on est disque
d'or déjà avec l'album est donc je suis
assez content voilà c'est une bonne note
us qui fait ça marche je suis ça
m'énerve
ouais alors est-ce que tu connais
orlando au toit oui on travaille pas
ensemble mais je le connais il était
souvent à la table à côté d'avesnes et
où tu va regarder ta caméra c'est le
cadre où j'en suis je regarde la caméra
c'est le diable rouge et tu vas dire
magnéto serge magnéto serge bien